and now standing at five foot seven
inches five nine if you count the heels
straight out of Great Lakes High School
the prettiest girl in Oh Caliban
[Applause]
[Laughter]
high-fives Manila okay oh honey I never
thought I'd see you in a dress
secondly it's a full dress and material
is missing from the middle here you look
great
all right yeah I think it's time to go
yes yeah honey we gotta go honey daddy
okay it's like when you watch the frozen
Julie left her laptop open because our
still be on our kids no we don't
understand what they're saying so it's
not snooping I love POSIX just saw
inferno
yeah great what do they say okay so
there's something about an eggplant hint
hanji eggplant agreement yeah they've
got an agreement to make eggplant
parmesan
no a plants are Dixon teenage emoji
language what you know what that's true
Julie told me that that the emojis have
they all have secret meanings so like
trees are weed and snowflakes are
cocaine and that thing is you squeeze
awkward you've never heard of the Osprey
no all right grandpa this is sex if I've
ever seen it
illustrated in image Oh No No maybe no
they're best friends they're just saying
like you're okay with me you're okay to
me I'm in what I'm in I'm having sex
tonight to just like that no I mean why
not because it's your first time and
your first time should be special and
perfect yours can be special and perfect
mine is gonna be tonight and with that
dude just Brown Connor Aldrich your lab
partner listen my student athlete days
are over tonight is the beginning of my
adult life and for the first time I can
do whatever I want so I want to go to
prom get drunk
potted up on weed and lose my goddamn
virginity we're gonna have the same
first time sex anniversary we can go to
dinner everyone commemorate it right fix
for life [ __ ] I have seen every single
fast and furious movie okay
all of them dozens of times have you
seen any of them I thought the turkey I
went and I saw the one where the rock
pinches the torpedo
those are the best two to see okay in
times like this I ask myself one
question WWV dee dee you know what that
means
what would Vin Diesel do
no one's ever gotten that before okay
what we're gonna do gonna kiss the
bumper you give it a little tap and
they're gonna spit and stop and we're
gonna spin and stop this away and we're
gonna look at each other and we're gonna
go it's all about the family way I don't
feel comfortable raining the kids off
the road this flow and unserious
attitude is not helping us you have to
believe okay there's something that
happens with your best friends where you
do everything together perfect I'm
having sex I'm in I'm having sex tonight
too and with that dude action I really
wanted to direct something that shows
young women in a way that hasn't been
shown before I am fully planning on
having sex tonight
wherever the night takes us the night's
gonna take us there wherever the wind
sails our ships your ship is going into
my Harbor I really love it it's just
like I'm totally different I feel like
prom is the catalyst of young women
stepping into adulthood
welcome the Jewish thing is planning so
she's like perfect friends perfect
boyfriend and she's going to have the
perfect prom no matter what Sam she's
definitely the nerdy or one miss which
had into to don't think that's how that
works
Mikaela lose her virginity is just
another way to break the rules I think
Julie left earth at top of it some kind
of a big plan agreement the mix I'm
gonna stop him I'm in it's about young
women in their sexuality and a double
standard sex can be very confusing the
first time the kids go on a journey and
sort of the adults they're gonna wait
WWV didi what would Vin Diesel do I
think we all want to stop too because
we're all just afraid of letting go
I'm not some pathetic damsel in distress
that needs saving I'm actually totally
[ __ ] everyone stays really true to
themselves and that's what's so special
about it and you see these girls and
they're growing up you're a woman
amongst girls but I do think that's
really important that young women can
look and understand if you're confused
understand if there's a struggle and
feel normal and feel okay we go hard or
go home
[Music]
we're gonna have the same first time sex
anniversary make you go to dinner
everyone commemorate breadsticks for
life I think our daughters are friends I
think it makes us friends I'm hunter I'm
Julie Mitchell Hills hero I can't
believe it's prompt they're so grown up
my daughter anymore boobs just - because
our still beyond our kids though we
don't understand what they're saying so
if you're not snooping oh my god teenage
emoji eggplants are dicks all emojis
have a secret meaning so like trees are
we and this thing is your screen so
she's gonna get rosy kiss and then touch
his dick eggplant
gonna drool come out of this - that's
just stare down it is look it's coffee
this is a sex act they're planning on
losing their virginity on prom night
maybe that's not sex they're just saying
you're okay with me maybe our girls are
not thinking things through I'm gonna
stop him I'm in let's [ __ ] block those
[ __ ] this is our last big night
together this Patrick's gonna make snot
even more perfect away WWV dee dee what
would Vin Diesel do
[Music]
in terms of prices parents are known to
have superhumans Joe do this
so messed up your dad try to stop you
when you wanted to lose your virginity
was too busy high-fiving
I'll do anything for my daughter what
about a little chugging contests
bringing home that westward but Chuck
you got this dog no I'm tagging out
you're in what you put a baby
everything's looser down there baby out
of my back on the count of three when I
am tripping so hard I just had a vision
my dad was chugging beer it was [ __ ]
[Music]